hi everyone I am Matthias maritza and
I'm Megan Reardon
so our talk is titled fantastic neural
networks and where to find them and we
are going to talk about this new product
which is the bolt from neural net
repository a system for distributing and
accessing easily neural network
resources
so good morning everyone Mattel she's
Megan and we're here to tell you about
this fantastic new product which is the
wall for neural net repository it's been
quite an effort to come to this point
but this is now released and so Megan
will start giving you an introduction
about what is it okay so basically a
little bit of background for why we have
this
so it's comprehensive we have a large
assortment of high quality net models
there which are updated regularly and
also the all of the models are
pre-trained which saves you training
time and also some of the training sets
are not publicly available so it would
be difficult for you to train your own
net exactly the same way and the the
last thing that's really nice about it
is that everything is within the Wolfram
language so there's no need to import
from other frameworks you can just go
right there get the model that you want
you can use it as is if you'd like
if not you can take it apart take
certain layers out add them to other
things make make new models of your own
or do different things with the the
models that are there all of the models
all have both a trained network and an
untrained network and so if you'd like
you can take the untrained Network and
train it with different data and then
lastly you can submit your own which
we'll talk about later on in the
presentation
so this is the actual the actual data
repository neural net repository alright
so as you can see everything is
organized by task type and then I don't
know if you can see but there's also a
little subtitle that tells you the
purpose of the network sort of more
specifically
I don't think yeah we don't have it it's
not linked but it will be linked from
the the regular data repository as well
you can actually it's it's live you can
just go to that web address oh sorry no
but I'll put it there yeah okay that's
because it's a soft release it's not
like full release so it's not being
advertised yet yeah of course of course
so then in addition to being organized
by task type you can I mean yeah by task
type you can also like their little
icons here that you can see which image
which input domain it is so whether it's
image or text or there will be audio and
numeric as well but we don't have any
yet so if you just I think so Bob showed
some of this yesterday but here it is
again so there's a certain amount of
metadata that that goes along with the
network and so it'll tell you a little
bit about the purpose of the net and
then some background about it some
training information with links to the
data sets that were used if they're
available you can also download the
example notebook or just look at the
examples on the net and and you can
download the construction notebook as
well and then there are references
so here let me
okay so let's start with some examples
so we'll start with an image and then
grab the so we're going to do
classification first so we'll start with
general purpose object classification so
this is the Wolfram image identify net
and then let's see what it identifies
those images all right so that's correct
see the top five probabilities here
so this this kind of networks for
general purposes classification are like
the they that they play a central role
in in computer in deep learning applied
to computer vision
they're basically used as a building
block for a lot of more you know fancy
applications and they are very powerful
they're always they they usually train
on huge data sets the major one being
image nets so for this category of
models we have like quite a few we have
I think we have like around 10 models
they're all like so most of the stuff in
this repository is actually are actually
poor things of like state of the art
officially release models from other
frameworks into our own framework so if
you're familiar with you will find a
couple of version of google nets you
will find in PG 1619 ResNet and more
stuff will come image the image identify
network is the for now it's the only
network which is not a port of external
model but it's something made by us but
more more more stuff like that will come
yeah so here's another one so this is
this is a fine tune of the inception
with one network trained on the image
net data sets on a new data set which is
a kind of common practice in eLearning
so this thing was trained on this data
set called the extended salient objects
appetising data set which is basically
data set about counting how many objects
are are in an image regardless of their
nature and so that it's kind of working
fine because they say there's there are
two guys there and you can see that
these are the probabilities and you can
see that it's pretty confident that
there are two two objects there it's 95
99 percent
ladies so also the next next guy this is
saying architecture inception we want so
Google Nets very famous this was trained
from scratch on the place it 365 data
set which is not an object recognition
data set like image net and so on but
it's a scene recognition data set so it
basically tells you not the object in an
image but like where is it like that
some classes like I don't know like
living room yeah that was hard one I
didn't believe that you know that that
stuff at the dead star among its classes
and so it's you know quite not sure
what's happening there Bauer music
studio okay this may be probably even a
tougher one because this is supposed to
show you the location on the earth a
photo was taken so it probably doesn't
have the location of the Dead star as
well okay New York City okay interesting
yeah as with the other networks you can
take the top probabilities you were
taking the 50 most confident locations
and okay somewhere in Europe or in the
US or yeah perhaps okay so
yeah I'll tell you how the these data
set is constructed so basically actually
this is a massive data set like millions
of images and they were annotated we the
actual like latitude longitude the peak
was taken those location were then like
put in a grid of like what it's 15,000
locations around the earth and and so
basically the data set was were were
composed by pairs of image and the index
from one of these 15 tells the location
and you can see it here let's scroll up
okay can you see this this is the last
layer this is the last softmax and the
dimensionality of this ahkamaat softmax
is actually 15 thousands can you see
this number okay
so these this is a classifier okay so it
tells you how confident it is for each
location that that peak has been taken
in that location so what we did here is
we took the word for this Han Solo and
Chewbacca image we have taken the most
the 50 locations the network is more
confident and we've plotted them with
the actually the the size of these
circle being proportional to the
probability sorry yeah but the top one
was New York City for some reason as you
can see and it's basically that the
biggest circle here that's why we got
you get New York City if you don't
specify even the top 50 probabilities
but you only say you know just tell me
where this pick was taken it's picking
the maximum automatically but you can
ask for more information image
processing yeah so we decided
classification we have these are more
about more fancy tasks so what is this
so these these was another pretty much
state of the art model so this thing is
a
we call this role model as weak as you
can see here so why what does it mean
exactly so we are tagging as role models
basically models which will not give you
the the final result straight away but
you have to do some more work on that
this will change in the future because
we're good so basically this is for
models which needs like some processing
like outside neural net processing so
you get the output for neural networks
but in order to get what you actually
want which is the the colored image you
have to do a bit of work yeah yeah this
is actually not just Riggin yeah okay so
in this case this thing is outputting
the the a and B channels of the la peak
our space so we we give it we gave a
grayscale image inputs and it will
output the amb channels of the colored
image in the LA bit color space so what
you have to do is to merge them with the
luminance from the original grayscale
image and that's what that evaluation
function is doing this will change in
the future so this thing will be bundled
inside what you get by doing Nets model
but right now we still not support for
that so we are talking these these guys
as role models but they will be updated
in the future ok so let's move on this
is that decimation model so this will
this will pretty much self-explanatory
will produce you def map and you can do
nice cool visualization of that and you
can also superimpose the original image
so you get a 3d representation of those
two guys that's a very cool one so if
you've never seen style transfer in your
life it will blow your mind
Wow
this thing is one of the methods for the
built-in function imagery style which we
are going to compare with
it's not exactly the same I can tell you
why if you're curious but you can see
that yeah yeah it's almost the same yeah
the point is that it it adapts the the
network to the actual size of the image
while the the vanilla network has fixed
the size input and outputs and so it
gives you a square image you can change
it in the framework like you can resize
the network and do it an image that does
it for you automatically that's it then
you make you stylus other methods but we
will talk about that those No okay so
here's another fun part we have quite a
few Network for facial analysis luckily
fine faces also found Chewbacca's face
so we are going to run all these fashion
Isis Network on both yes they only work
on yeah so the fun part is that you know
what what will happen when they see
Chewbacca's face which is not actually a
face so this thing tells you the age and
it's pretty much failing for Han Solo
too but next thing you can do with this
model is that you can actually visualize
you know histogram of probabilities for
the age so the blue thing is unsolo and
the red thing is Chewbacca so strange
this doesn't happen often but you see
that for Han Solo it has like two peaks
the biggest one is it was slightly
bigger bigger it was like 13 year old
and then there is a peak around watts 50
or something so like the average was
probably the red check the right one for
white Rebecca is peaked at 13 for
whatever reason general prediction Oh
amazing and you can see that for hunt
solo is pretty you know it's pretty sure
it's a male but for Chubbuck are not so
rose then we have facial key points
models so this thing these guys were
simple it's it's telling you the
position of the eyes and the nose and
the mouth but actually too much more
powerful model
so we're just brought in so we don't
have them here but you will find them in
the repo and they will identify 68 key
points per image and that's pretty
accurate for two back as well this is
very cool
the last one we showing you this is for
basically from an image of a face it
will regress a 3d facial model so I've
cheated here because like I'm using as
official crop of slightly bigger size
than what fine faces produces because
otherwise it wouldn't detect Han Solo's
face you can rotate this guy and you can
extract so this is a three dimensional
array of pixel intensities which you can
show with image 3d and you can extract
the facial 3d mesh as well from that and
you can rotate that as well okay so this
super quick Rush is over we're gonna
take questions oh no sorry
so so in addition to being able to use
what's already up there you can submit
your own like so we have a nice
definition notebook for that which is
not live at the moment but will be soon
so if you're really antsy to submit your
own right away you can go ahead and fill
out the notebook and then send us a
message on the contact us part of the
repository and we can figure out how to
get it in there
but this will be up very shortly so
there's a certain amount of metadata
that you can add here and then you can
indicate the task type and the input
domains and then there's a preparation
area so if you'd like to just do
everything right in the notebook you can
do that or if you want you can just like
cloud object or a local object or
something like that really all you need
to add in is the evaluated detrained net
here and then you would put in whatever
examples you want to show and then if
you want to put a link
you're testing data you can put that as
well and then you can you should provide
a construction notebook as well which
you can either upload here or you can do
it longhand like the example notebook
where you put everything in here and
both the example notebook and the
construction notebook will be turned
into anything you put in here will be
turned into a notebook that can be
downloaded straight from the repository
and then you would create your resource
object and if you can either deploy it
locally you can deploy it to the cloud
if you'd like share it with other people
or if you'd like to submit it you would
need a publisher ID and then you can
submit it to the repository probably
within a week or two max and and then we
can take some questions
yeah so it's Network will run on on any
hardware of course you so deep learning
GPU is important but it's you're not
tied to GPU and so the purpose of this
repository is mainly to give you models
which are ready for evaluation it's not
about really training models these are
pre-trained models that you can use so
chip the part where GPU is very crucial
is training so of course the peer
evaluation is faster than CP evaluation
but
yeah
so we are so by the most recent standard
you program include a nine
so the perspective is different so when
you are using these kind of models you
don't have to care about all these GPU
thing stuff at all if you have an NVIDIA
GPU with the correct drivers it will
just run we are we are bundling the cuda
installation inside the product and
anyway and you don't see it it's it's
transparent to the user so usually in
external deep learning promotes you have
to set up cooler yourself so you have to
download the recorded version of CUDA
you have to compile it you have to link
it to whatever frameworks you're using
it can be a mixed network a fair torch
or whatever and you have to stuff
yourself here as soon as you install
Mathematica everything just works so as
for the version of CUDA we didn't who we
didn't hook up CUDA 9 yet
we are running aids we will hook up good
9 soon but anyway as soon as you have a
working Japan meter GPU with the correct
drivers if we just run using whatever
version of cool a bundle in sorry you
don't you don't have to care about
nothing yes so it's if you want to run
on GPU there's an option for Network
evaluation let's do net of the input
comma target device those two GPU and if
you learn interview so it's but it's
very simple
run
well that's that's another approach to
finish another regression but these guys
more powerful you can do it with one
then of course you may argue okay if I
have to when I get better results of
course but that's what not what that
model is designed to work with so that
thing only is designed to work on a
single image and produce Giovanni then
of course you may find like other models
which needs more data and will possibly
be better but that's the only 3d facial
regression model we have yet but like
this project it will be evolving
constantly so there are about 40 models
in the repository
but it will just grow so you may find
some for that as well in the future so
our policy for so our policy for
accepting submission will be basically
that we will only check that the the
metadata and the submission is formally
correct so it has the current meta data
it has what is needed to AB like the
files and and the examples and that's it
and possibly not being a network about a
completely ridiculous task but we are
not basically checking for the
performance of of the external
submission because that would be a very
time-consuming task and it's also kind
not outside the scope of this because it
is more about sharing so even if you had
something which it's not you know the
best team is in the world for the task
but nevertheless you want to share we do
it with the outside world you can submit
it and if the submission is formally
correct Alaska will accept it
yeah no there is no rating system but
that's that's a good idea we're thinking
about that yeah any suggestions like
that you can submit to the contact us
so in in deep learning for computer
vision usually what people do usually is
working on images between 200 and 500 or
600 pixel size depending on the task you
have to do so for for general-purpose
classification so light image not models
and so on the usual size is 224 so that
that thing is enough like a to 24 by 24
image has enough information for the
network to figure out what's inside it's
basically four different kind of tasks
you may want lightly higher resolution
like like for example image processing
tasks like fruit I know the that's
exactly the style transfer Network for
those kind of tasks
people usually shift to more like bigger
sizes but it doesn't really make much of
a difference usually it's very rare to
to find something which was trained and
it's supposed to be valued in a thousand
by thousand images main just because it
will bloat your memory usually yep
imagery style thing yeah
yeah
so okay we want to attract that with you
later
but usually it so this kind of
processing is very intensive processing
so running a deep network on a very big
image can easily blow blow to your
memory GPU or CPU memory so that's more
or less no surprise but I'll check it at
check in detail with you
that's a tough one so that's a nice one
so for our side it took about eight
months to get the sporty models but of
course we got much better at doing it
after some time so there was like a slow
transient so it strongly also depend by
the internal effort of the company like
how many people work on that which is
quite unclear but I mean it's it's
something we care about and we are
trying to get more people yes exactly we
are trying to get more people working on
these so I would expect probably ten
models a month or something like that
and that's for the conversion part so we
take a state-of-the-art release
open-source Network done by someone else
and you import it in the framework then
there it after some time we will start
doing training ourselves for internal
purposes and some of these networks
which we now set will be also released
here so that that will probably get it
would get fast after some point after we
also started in our model students